Philipp Mickenbecker auf dem Weg
zum Brötchen holen.
Hallo!
Ja, super. Dankeschön. Bitteschön.
Die fliegende Badewanne „Marke
Eigenbau“ ist nur
eine der rund zwanzig
verrückten Erfindungen
der YouTube-Zwillinge „The Real Life Guys“.
Heute wollen Philipp und Johannes
Mickenbecker ein Kinderfahrzeug gegen
einen Kleinwagen antreten lassen.
Dafür soll das Spielzeug
einen Motor bekommen.
Wie immer bauen die
22- Jährigen alles selbst.
Ja, also gelernt in die Richtung haben wir
eigentlich nichts, das haben wir uns alles eher
mit YouTube-Tutorials beigebracht
und alles irgendwie gegoogelt.
Unser Vater hat uns auch ein bisschen
geholfen am Anfang,
mit Fahrrädern zu basteln und so.
Die elterliche Garage in der Nähe von
Frankfurt am Main dient als Werkstatt.
Damit das Tretauto das Körpergewicht
eines jungen Erwachsenen halten kann,
schweißen die Brüder ein
zusätzliches Stahlgerüst ein.
Der Motor läuft akkubetrieben.
Ja, das Problem war, dass unendlich
viel Strom erst mal hier durchfließt,
so dass der Regler uns
explodiert ist, der letzte.
Deswegen haben wir jetzt ewig lang
gebraucht, einen Motor zu finden
und einen Regler, die wirklich für so viel
Strom gemacht sind.
Ähm ja,
ich hoffe mal, dass der uns jetzt nicht
wieder hoch geht, wenn wir‘s testen.
2016 begannen die eineiigen Zwillinge damit,
ihre Erfinder-Videos auf YouTube zu posten.
Mittlerweile werden sie bei den meisten
Aktionen von Sponsoren unterstützt.
Mit ihren Projekten möchten die
Real Life Guys andere motivieren,
selbst aktiv zu werden.
Ja, weil wir glauben, dass da heutzutage
ziemlich viele Leute nur noch eben
vorm Computer sitzen und gar nicht
mehr richtig was draußen machen.
Und ich glaub‘, das Gefühl, irgendwie
was selber draußen was zu machen,
ist immer noch tausendmal schöner
als irgendetwas Virtuelles zu erleben.
Mittlerweile hat ihr Youtube-Kanal rund
940.000 Abonnenten.
Die beiden können inzwischen
hauptberuflich davon leben.
Ihr Ingenieursstudium haben sie
abgebrochen.
Das praktische Arbeiten liegt ihnen mehr.
Zum Beispiel der Bau eines motorisierten
360-Grad-Schaukelstuhls.
Wir waren mal damit auf so‘ ner … in so
‘nem Skatepark und sind diese Rampen
runtergefahren, das war
auch ziemlich spektakulär.
Da ist es uns wirklich richtig
schlecht geworden dabei.
Eine Menge Aufsehen erregte
auch dieses Objekt:
Ja, das ist unser U-Boot. Und ich glaub‘,
das ist wirklich das Bekannteste,
aber auch das Gefährlichste,
was wir jemals gebaut haben.
Hier ist ein Loch, und jetzt kommt
mega das Wasser rein.
Ich versuch‘s zuzuhalten,
aber das bringt alles nix.
Das war knapp. Ja, wir machen schon
manchmal gefährliche Sachen,
aber wir versuchen schon immer
aufzupassen, vorher halt abzuschätzen,
was irgendwie zu riskant ist und
was man noch machen kann.
Also hier hatten wir zum Beispiel
nen Taucher dabei,
wir hatten drinnen ne Sauerstoffflasche,
und ein Seil hatten wir hinten dran,
also wir haben uns eigentlich
schon abgesichert.
Zeit für die nächste Herausforderung:
Das Tretauto ist startklar
- mit einer Motorleistung von 20 PS.
Johannes tritt damit gegen seinen Bruder
Philipp an, im 90 PS-starken Kleinwagen.
Wir sind jetzt hier auf dieser
neugebauten Straße
und fahren ein Rennen gegen den Fabia.
Ich bin saugespannt, aber ich glaub‘
schon, dass ich das packe.
Ja die Beschleunigung von
dem Ding ist jetzt ultrakrass,
aber die Höchstgeschwindigkeit nicht so.
Also müssen wir schauen,
dass wir am Anfang richtig raushauen,
damit wir den nachher auch kriegen.
Meistens helfen Freunde der Zwillinge mit,
wie hier beim Aufbau einer Kartonmauer
als Ziellinie nach 200 Metern.
Auf die Plätze - fertig - los!
Geil, herzlichen Glückwunsch!
Danke, danke.
Und wie war's? Habt ihr das erwartet?
Kurze Bewertung bitte!
Äh, also ich hätte niemals gedacht,
dass er so schnell beschleunigt…
Aber es ist schon… es war sehr knapp.
Die Beschleunigung ist schon geil,
aber ich glaub‘, die Endgeschwindigkeit
kann ich lange nicht mithalten.
Am Anfang hat es richtig reingehauen,
aber am Ende hab' ich schon gemerkt,
wie ich schneller geworden bin.
Und dann … es war sehr knapp, aber...
Ich denke, wir bauen‘s noch mal ‘n
bisschen stärker, das kriegen wir noch hin.
Ja.
Die Ideen gehen den beiden Erfindern
jedenfalls so schnell nicht aus.
Ein fliegendes Auto ist schon in Planung.